la neumonía es una infección que causa
inflamación irritación y una acumulación
de moco en los pulmones usted tiene dos
pulmones uno a cada lado del pecho cada
pulmón tiene secciones separadas
llamadas lóbulos normalmente a medida
que usted inhala el aire circula
libremente a través de la tráquea y
luego a través de grandes conductos
llamados bronquios a través de conductos
más pequeños llamados bronquiolos
y finalmente entra en unos pequeños
sacos llamados alveolos normalmente las
vías respiratorias y los alvéolos son
flexibles y elásticos cuando respira
cada alveolos bolsa de aire se infla
como un pequeño globo y cuando exhala
los alveolos se desinflan
hay pequeños vasos sanguíneos llamados
capilares que rodean los alveolos
y el oxígeno del aire que usted respira
pasa a través de los capilares a
continuación el dióxido de carbono de su
cuerpo sale de los capilares hacia los
alveolos para que sus pulmones puedan
deshacerse de él cuando exhala
si usted tiene neumonía sus vías
respiratorias o los pulmones tienen una
infección causada por gérmenes tales
como bacterias
y virus
hongos
o parásitos
las vías respiratorias capturan la
mayoría de los gérmenes en el moco que
recubre la tráquea los bronquios y los
bronquiolos los cilios proyecciones
similares a cabellos que recubren los
tubos empujan constantemente el moco y
los gérmenes de las vías respiratorias
donde usted puede expulsarlos por medio
de la tos a veces los microbios pasan
más allá del moco y los cilios y entran
en los alveolos
normalmente las células de su sistema
inmunológico atacan estos gérmenes e
impiden que usted se enferme sin embargo
si su sistema inmunológico está
debilitado por la edad una enfermedad o
la fatiga los gérmenes causantes de la
neumonía pueden superar a sus células
inmunes y comenzar a multiplicarse
los bronquiolos y alvéolos se inflaman e
irritan a medida que su sistema inmune
ataca los gérmenes que se multiplican
como resultado los alveolos se llenan de
líquido lo que dificulta que su cuerpo
obtenga el oxígeno que necesita si usted
tiene neumonía lobular uno de los
lóbulos de los pulmones se ve afectado
si usted tiene una bronconeumonía varias
áreas de ambos pulmones están afectados
la neumonía puede causar los siguientes
síntomas dificultad para respirar dolor
en el pecho todos
fiebre y escalofríos confusión dolor de
cabeza dolor muscular y fatiga
la neumonía puede dar lugar a
complicaciones graves
la insuficiencia respiratoria se produce
cuando la respiración se vuelve tan
difícil que se necesita una máquina
llamada respirador que lo ayude a
respirar
y la septicemia se produce cuando las
bacterias causantes de la neumonía pasan
al torrente sanguíneo donde pueden
viajar e infectar a otros órganos
en algunos casos de neumonía puede
formarse una gran acumulación de líquido
y pus llamada absceso dentro de uno de
sus pulmones
y los posibles tratamientos para la
neumonía incluyen antibióticos y la
causa es una bacteria o un parásito
y medicamentos antivirales y la causa es
un virus de la gripe
y medicamentos antimicóticos si la causa
es un hongo
y descansar y beber líquidos en
abundancia
y tomar medicamentos de venta libre etc
para manejar los dolores de la fiebre y
otros dolores
si usted tiene neumonía grave puede ser
admitido en el hospital y recibir
antibióticos por vía intravenosa y
oxígeno si tiene preguntas acerca de la
neumonía o cualquier tratamiento que le
hayan recetado consulte a su médico